gainsbourg toujours si présent si proche
la poésie des mots l'incroyable talent
de mélodiste et d'arrangeur un artiste
irremplaçable l'homme à la tête de shoot
de personnes gainsbourg le tendre et
gainsbarre le provocateur que personne
n'arrive à oublier dix ans après sa
disparition
relisez les wasaï frédérick basile
garçon de 31 mai pour la peinture la
musique la chanson il sait le faire
faire son trou son titre ou que devra
grandement de la chanson ch gars vous
suit poinçonneur des lilas le gars qu'on
croise quand on regarde pas
il ya pas de soleil sous la terre dont
l'itinéraire d'un révolutionnaire son
crime détournement d'art mineur
d'abord c'est moi et tout à fait et
chanson française est affaires actuelles
jouable
nous avons 30
n'en finissent pas de mouret
cachée de peinture je détruisais toutes
mes toiles ce qui fait qu'il n'en reste
aucune et maintenant je peux pas
détruire mais disent parce que
il m'appartient plus
pianiste de bar à mouvaux de boris vian
gainsbourg s'attaque à toutes les
musiques
j'écris des chansons difficile en
chansons faciles en déchets que je
sacrifie au commercial
fiche pas la tête
manon
ma non
non
il rêvait de peinture ses modèles serge
gainsbourg d'aller poser pour l'éternité
sur la toile de ses mots
et
ce
du
l'homme à la tête de chou dans ses bras
les plus jolies femmes dans son coeur à
jamais une seule demeure oui
j'aime cette fille je peux le dire
personne
privée du tenue scénique gainsbourg
adopte une tenue cynique mais le racket
de bien ce que je dis aux silhouettes
s'arrêterait à 74%
il faut quand même pas déconner suis
assoupi
et que redonner à la pensée y est son
sens initial
et
le jour de gloire l'acquisition du
manuscrit original de l'hymne national
sinon rouge et de lits pour 135 mille
francs
la victoire du dandy misogyne et
misanthrope
que j'ai écrit
j'aime mon métier j'ai pas fini et je
travaillais avec ça
il ya des mamans puissent apparaître
c'est vrai que j'étais petit
jose reyes fait pas brouiller des objets
de caillan le basque à gainsbarre s'est
jouée de gainsbourg
grecque c'est moi qui suis le fossoyeur
du cimetière l'apathie thürer reste une
image souriante celle d'un homme pudique